[Music]
what if one day everyone on earth pulled
their Forks away from their steaks and
turned vegan whether for the sake of a
healthier lifestyle to alleviate and all
suffering or to fight global warming
everyone found their own reason to say
no to a juicy burger a fluffy omelette
or a cheesy pizza even ice cream would
make the nono list what a vegan diet
saved the planet from climate change
would this improve your health what
would happen to all those cattle this is
what if and here's what would happen if
everyone in the world became vegan there
are 20 million vegans in the US alone
six times more than there were in 2015
tofu is filling in for me on restaurant
menus dairy-free milk alternatives are
pushing their way onto supermarket
shelves
what was once a radical diet choice is
becoming mainstream did you know food
produced by animals is responsible for a
quarter of all greenhouse gas emissions
most of that comes from cows every year
the world's cattle population leaves a
carbon footprint equivalent to the co2
emissions of every car train ship and
aircraft in the world put together wait
how exactly does livestock contribute to
global warming there's about a billion
and a half cows in the world each cow
releases up to a hundred and twenty
kilograms of methane per year on the
climate change scale methane's negative
effect is 23 times higher than carbon
dioxides on top of that cattle take as
much as two-thirds of all agricultural
land on the planet if we all went vegan
we'd use most of that pasture land for
restoring forests and grasslands to help
reduce carbon dioxide in the air we
start growing more crops to fill the
gaps in our food supply
livestock related gas emissions would
drop by 70%
but what would happen to all those farm
animals with no demand for grilled
chicken and roast beef billions of
animals would be slaughtered or
abandoned some animals like sheep and
pigs might be able to return to the wild
but their numbers would drop due to
predators others though like broiler
chickens couldn't survive in the wild is
they're so far removed from their
testers they wouldn't know what to do
their best chance might be in
sanctuaries where they'd be taken care
of until they die out your local butcher
would have to find another job and so
would millions of farmers they could
start growing more crops or restoring
forests but on a large scale rural
communities that used to supply you with
milk eggs and meat would face
significant unemployment developing
countries who built their lives and
trades around livestock would deal with
major economic disruption but everyone
would be a little bit healthier or would
we adopting a vegan diet doesn't
automatically make you a healthy eater
vegans often miss out on vital nutrients
they often don't get enough calcium iron
vitamin D zinc vitamin b12 or omega-3
fatty acids since meat eggs and cheese
would no longer be served as a perfect
source of protein you'd have to eat a
lot of beans soy and lentils but with a
proper diet we'd suffer from less
coronary heart disease stroke and
diabetes global mortality rates would
drop by up to 10%
this would mean 8 million less deaths
per year and up to 1 trillion dollars
saved on health care and lost working
days annually but not in developing
countries where over two billion people
already faced massive undernourishment
without meat for them things wouldn't
get healthier they'd get worse having
the entire world go vegan might be a
little extreme but keeping foods
produced by animals in our diet means we
will eventually have to deal with the
gas emissions luckily for those hooked
on meat
clean solutions to reduce emissions from
the livestock industry already exist all
that's left is to implement them what
about you would you say no to your
meatball pasta tonight
[Music]